ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. HURRY
ARAMBULA. BAUER-KAHAN IN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DEEP. EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO. SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY
OSHA RIVER NOTION. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A MOMENT OF REFLECTION.
NOT LONG AGO WE ARE SHOPPING AT
COSTCO. IT IS DIFFICULT TO
ESCAPE WITHOUT A CAR FULL OF
ASSORTED ITEMS. WHILE WAITING
AT THE END OF ONE OF THE MANY
LONG CHECKOUT LINES RIGHT
BEHIND US WITH AN ANXIOUS
ITEMS. I TURN AND SUGGESTED HE
GO ON AHEAD OF US. HE QUICKLY
SAID NO THAT'S ALRIGHT. WE
ASSURED HIM THAT WE WERE IN NO
HURRY AND IT DIDN'T MAKE MUCH
SENSE FOR HIM TO WAIT FOR OUR
CART LOAD OF THINGS TO BE
SCANNED. THEN HE COULD BE ON
HIS WAY. RELUCTANTLY HE SAID
WELL OKAY BANKS. WHILE WE
WAITED WE NOTICED HOW HIS
DEMEANOR CHANGED. NO LONGER
ANXIOUS HE SMILED AS WE WAITED
TOGETHER AND CHATTED ABOUT THE
LONG LINE. AFTER HE PURCHASES
FEW ITEMS HE TURNED AND LEFT US
WITH THE WAVE AND A SMILE
BANKING US ONCE AGAIN. BOB SAID
THAT WAS NICE AND I AGREED
ALTHOUGH IN THE GLOBAL SCHEME
OF THINGS. IT DID NOT SEEM TO
MAKE MUCH DIFFERENCE. IN A VERY
SMALL WAY. THERE WAS A FEELING
THAT THE WORLD WAS NOW HELLO
KINDER FRIENDLIER PLACE TO LIVE.
EVERY DAY IN WASTE GREAT AND
SMALL EACH OF US CAN MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE WE ONLY
NEED TO TRY. NUMBER ONE THE
NUMBER WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER FALL. A PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE SALUTE
PLEDGE. AND SERIAL- OF SAN JUAN.
FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO FRIDAY EVERYWHERE
TEAM TWENTY TWENTY IT'S ONLY
MINUTE NINE AM ON A REBEKAH
BARRICADE HAND ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THIS ON THE
PRESIDING SHE COOKS TO PARKER
AT THE DESK READING CLERK
MESSENGER CALDERON MOVES. AND
MR BRO SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH. VISITATIONS
AMPUTATIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA FOR PERSONAL
SHIRLEY WEBER IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JAY OBERNOLTE FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
AND FOR MATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER SB SET FIVE
SEVENTY THREE CHIANG FROM THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY. MEMBERS. MISTER
PATTERSON YOU HAVE GUESTS IN
THE GALLERY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND-
MEMBERS AS A CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AVIATION CAUCUS I'M
DELIGHTED TO OFFICIALLY KICK
OFF THE TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION DAYS AT OUR CAPITAL
THIS EVENT IS HELD HERE EVERY
YEAR TO INFORM LEGISLATORS
STAFF IN THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE INDUSTRIES
TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND TO
RAISE AWARENESS OF THE BENEFITS
OF AEROSPACE AND AVIATION. TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH A
COMBINED CONTRIBUTION OF OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO THE
STATE AND WITH OVER ONE MILLION
INDIVIDUALS EMPLOYED
CALIFORNIA'S AVIATION AND
AEROSPACE INDUSTRIES CONTINUE
TO BE MAJOR ECONOMIC LEADERS AS
I MENTIONED WE ARE GOING TO
KICK OFF SEVERAL DAYS OF THE
AVIATION. AND AEROSPACE OUT
EVENTS HERE AT THE CAPITAL. IN
PREPARATION FOR THIS I WANT TO
INTRODUCE WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS
REPRESENTING SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT SIGNIFICANT
ASSOCIATIONS. IN THIS FIELD AT
AS I- INTRODUCED THE
ASSOCIATION THAT WAS MEMBERS
PLEASE STAY ON THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS IS HERE.
THE AIRCRAFT OWNERS AND PILOTS
ASSOCIATION. THE CALIFORNIA
PILOTS ASSOCIATION THE
EXPERIMENTAL AIRCRAFT
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL
BUSINESS AVIATION ASSOCIATION.
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
AIRPORT EXECUTIVES LOCKHEED
MARTIN THE ASSOCIATION OF
UNMANNED VEHICLE SYSTEMS
INTERNATIONAL AND THE AEROSPACE
STATES ASSOCIATION PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THEM AND
RECOGNIZING THEM FOR THEIR GOOD
SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER PATTERSON AND MISTER
OR SALAS YOU HAVE GUESTS AS
WELL IN THE GALLERY MISTER
SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR MY
DESK. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS- PLEASE JOIN ME WE
HAVE COUNCIL MEMBER ALL WRONG
FROM THE CITY OF SHAFTER WE
HAVE THE RITUAL IN JUNIOR HIGH
KIDS OR STUDENT BODY. CLASSES
UP HERE IN THE GALLERY WITH US
JOINING US TODAY WILL BE.
LEARNING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
FABULOUS WORK THAT WE DO HERE
AND SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM TO THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS ONE
TWO AND THREE ARE TO BE
CONTINUED.
NO PROBLEM. MEMBERS
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY SIXTH CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH FLOOR SESSION IS
AT NINE AM. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION. A QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED A GERMAN
TO MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS ARE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE AT A GERMAN TO MEMORY.
THE QUORUM CALL HAS BEEN LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY. MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM YOUR DESK. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER A- MEMBERS I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF WILLIAM WALKER.
WILLIAM WALKER FROM CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA I WAS A WORLD WAR
TWO VETERAN HE LIVED TO BE
ALMOST ONE HUNDRED YEARS OLD.
BILL WAS A LOVING FATHER AND
HUSBAND HE WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER
OF OUR COMMUNITY AS A ROTARIAN
AGAIN HE ON THAT I FOUR H. CLUB
LEADER. BILL GRADUATED FROM
JOHN MARSHALL HIGH SCHOOL HE
TOOK A JOB AS AN ELECTRICAL
INSTALLER. AT THE LOCKHEED VEGA
AIRCRAFT PLANT IN BURBANK. AND
WHEN WAR BROKE OUT IN DECEMBER
NINETEEN FORTY ONE. BILL
ENTERED THE U. S. NAVY FLIGHT
SCHOOL AND WAS COMMISSIONED AS
A LIEUTENANT. AND PILOTED DC
THREE IS FOR THE NAVAL AIR
TRANSPORT SERVICE IN THE SOUTH
PACIFIC. UPON RETURNING HOME
AFTER THE WAR BILL ATTENDED UC
BERKELEY HE EARNED A DEGREE IN
FOOD SCIENCE. SOON AFTER HE MET
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE NANCY THEY
WERE MARRIED IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SIX. HE JOINED A SAFEWAY STORES
IN NINETEEN SIXTY YOU MAINTAIN
A TWENTY FIVE YEAR CAREER IN
QUALITY ASSURANCE BEFORE
RETIRING IN STARTING HIS OWN.
NOVEL FOOD PRODUCTS COMPANY
WITH A FRIEND. BILL IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE NANCY THEIR THREE
CHILDREN LARA RICK AND KATHY
EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN. AND TWO
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN THE
MEMORY OF WILLIAM WALKER AND-
THANKING. HIM FOR A LIFE WELL
LIVED SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY IN
WORLD WAR TWO. AND THE GENEROUS
LIFE HE LIVED IN OUR MIDST IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
THANK YOU MEMBERS. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING HER IN A FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR GALLAGHER MOVES AND MISTER
MERCY CHEESE SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH AT NINE AM WE ARE
ADJOURNED.